[Música]
actualizamos las noticias de la economía
con Juan Pablo lucus y Juan Pablo vamos
ahora con nuestra segunda ronda si le
parece Así es acá estamos con más
noticias empezamos con Asia Pacífico
pero con un tema que le puede interesar
a nuestra audiencia en la región Así es
que Australia Busca Elevar el salario
mínimo para los migrantes calificados
que lleguen a ese país o que ya estén
ahí pero entonces usted Se preguntará
Por qué aumentar el salario de los
migrantes porque hacer este cambio Pues
según la ministra del interior algo que
debe cambiar en Australia y es lo que
ella llamó como un sistema de migración
defectuoso que fomenta la explotación y
pared y favorece la atracción de
empleados mal pagados en lugar de cubrir
la escasez crítica de habilidades
Australia ha tenido durante mucho tiempo
una de las tasas más altas de
inmigración de cualquier país que
pertenece a la organización para la
cooperación y el desarrollo económico
antes el umbral de ingreso mínimo para
los migrantes calificados si había
congelado en los
35.600 dólares al año esto desde 2013 y
no se había cambiado y ahora se espera
que cambie a partir del primero de julio
de este año hasta los
46.300 dólares me gustaría Angela que
escuchemos lo que piensa el actual
gobierno de los migrantes de ese país
nuestro sistema de migración está
sufriendo una década de abandono
realmente impresionante está roto está
fallando a nuestros negocios está
fallando a los propios migrantes y lo
más importante de todo está fallando a
los australianos Y eso no puede
continuar porque como país enfrentamos
grandes desafíos nacionales que la
migración nos puede ayudar a resolver
nuestra economía está atascada en una
rutina de productividad y los
australianos están sufriendo por ello la
migración puede ayudarnos a cambiar eso
sabe que normalmente no nos fijamos en
que las grandes economías del mundo
están hechas a partir de migrantes mire
el caso de Estados Unidos mire el Reino
Unido Pues
mira Canadá mire hacia Australia y es
importante que hagan este reconocimiento
al capital humano que finalmente está
construyendo los países y las economías
que es la base de todo si es así que
pues le concedo la emoción Por esta
noticia y vamos a cambiar ahora a
Estados Unidos a un panorama más difícil
la cámara de representantes ya probó
Elevar el la deuda pero esa discusión
está lejos de terminar así es y la
ampliación se hizo con condiciones
porque pues la condición impuesta por la
mayoría republicana en la cámara ha sido
rechazada por el gobierno de Joe biden y
además se espera que esta ley se hunda
en el senado ya que la mayoría es
demócrata para el presidente de la
cámara de representantes que vive
mccarthy lo que debería hacer Joe biden
es negociar esta propuesta escuchemos
hemos hecho nuestro trabajo me senté con
el presidente del primero de febrero me
ignoró el resto del tiempo está poniendo
la economía de Estados Unidos en peligro
por su falta de acción ahora debe
sentarse a negociar aprobamos esto
temprano estamos en abril muy por
delante del período límite de la deuda
ahora vamos con algunos cierres para
este tema y es el proyecto de ley del
techo de la deuda pasó a la cámara de
representantes por Solo dos votos de
diferencia de los 217 frente a los 215
que pues hubo otro de los datos es que
el 5 de junio es el día que el
departamento del tesoro estimó que
Estados Unidos podría caer por primera
vez en la historia en un default si el
congreso no resuelve esta situación y
otra es el tema de la preocupación el
escenario es preocupante porque un
diputado demócrata dijo que hay una
probabilidad de 7 sobre 10 de que la
catástrofe ocurra ya veremos ya veremos
y mientras tanto seguimos con los
resultados trimestrales de las grandes
empresas el día de hoy el turno es para
meta la casa matriz de Facebook Hoy es
el turno para meta Así es porque ayer
dio a conocer los resultados que tuvo
entre enero y marzo de este año los
ingresos de la compañía de este periodo
aumentaron un 3% hasta los 28.650
millones de dólares frente a los 27.670
millones de dólares estimados por
economistas de bloomberg lo llegó hasta
un 14% sus acciones esto en la apertura
de Wall Street hace unos pocos minutos
que representa uno de sus niveles más
altos históricamente el director de la
compañía Mark Zuckerberg dijo que ya
había terminado su Ronda de despidos de
los 11.000 puestos de trabajo que
anunció el año pasado pero ahora sigue
otra de por lo menos unos 10.000
despidos no se puede confiar vamos a los
indicadores bueno Y empezamos con la
apertura de Wall Street porque sus tres
principales indicadores tuvieron
ganancias sobre todo con el nasda con un
mayor del 1%. la mayoría de bolsas de
América Latina cerraron con pérdidas el
miércoles con la excepción de las bolsas
del Sur con Argentina y chile los
principales indicadores de Perú Brasil
México y Colombia tuvieron pérdidas las
bolsas en Europa se midieron por el
nuevo pronóstico de crecimiento que hizo
el Gobierno de Alemania sobre su
economía cuando duplicó su pronóstico y
pasó del 0,2% al 0,4% esto teniendo en
cuenta de que este país no tuvo tantos
problemas como se esperaba en la época
de invierno Juan Pablo gracias a usted
mañana nos vemos con mucho más aquí
estaremos